California is experiencing its most
serious drought in decades in about a
year the state's reservoirs could run
dry this is a serious crisis here's what
Californians are doing to make a change
I really care about the environment
that's my only locally grown food like
this almond uh but it takes about 1.1
gallons of water to make one almond and
that doesn't help because it was grown
in California yeah but isn't the most
important thing just to eat local no not
in this instance does it help that I'm
vegan let's move on let's see what this
couple is doing to make a change I'm
taking my girlfriend on a picnic but
instead of taking three jugs of water
I'm only gonna take two well why would
you need that many jokes of water in the
first place in case we get thirsty or we
decide to have a water fight again Maeve
loves water fights this is literally the
worst possible time water fights are
great they're fun yes do your water
fight thing so there's like a water
balloon
it's so cute it is so cute okay while
that is adorable
we need to be making more conscious
efforts like turning off the water when
we wash our hands are taking shorter
showers like this woman to conserve
water I'm only taking showers for five
minutes tops and she's starting today
well actually I'm probably gonna be
starting tomorrow so I got a huge date
tonight so probably gonna be at least 40
minutes playing wait this last guy he's
normal what are you doing - in the water
crisis sir the drought I thought this
was an audition for the walking dead
knew who I said if we didn't do this PSA
we all might be dead I still get paid
all right you know I quit all right
quick